do you think as he prepared for the
budget would have been a good idea if
he'd taken a walk down James Turner
Street come see you all on benefit
Street whether you've got some because
I'm gonna advise some good ideas and I
think he'd have gotten a little bit of a
grasp about like the real world and how
it is to you know how a majority of the
country is actually living at the moment
let's talk about benefits benefits a
huge part of overall government expended
yeah there's so many different types of
benefits out there there's so many
different types of people that are on
benefits
I think Housing Benefit needs to be
capped because I think there's an awful
lot being paid in rents and privately
rented accommodation the minimum wage
needs to go up to sort of come in line
with the cost of living it's you know
the car shopping Shapley's absolutely
extortion at nowadays it's like you know
the cost you a fortune just to sort of
to provide food for your children so the
cost of living at the heart of it but
you're on benefits dear on yeah well you
would like to work potentially if it was
economically viable no I think I would
like to work full stop obviously I am a
single parent I have got two children I
am on employment and Support Allowance
at the moment due to depression issues
and mental health issues but that
doesn't mean I just want to get that
under control at the moment it's not
under control so I don't feel that I am
fit to work but that doesn't mean that I
don't want to work but once again when I
do start working I still have to find a
job that pays me enough so I could still
live and you're going to use this
experience that you've had by appearing
becoming it television star I suppose it
has been it has been asked of me before
it has been said before and obviously
you know jokingly I've said yes so it's
been reported and I have had phone calls
from counters saying oh no you're not
going to be standing against me are you
and and I'd never dismiss the
possibility but even though it's not
even if you you can't make a difference
straightaway but I do think you need
more people in a position of power
who've got more of an understanding as
to
what the real person needs